"Не спокушайтеся: "Північний потік-2" принесе
не лише російський газ. Дном Балтійського моря
в Європу потече і російський вплив…"
Так про ризики залежності Євросоюзу від Росії
попереджає посол США у Німеччині РІчард Гренелл.
Разом з колегами - послами США в Данії та ЄС -
Карлою Сендс та Гордоном Сондлендом
у гостьовому коментарі на Дойче Велле він закликає
Європейський союз переглянути газову директиву
Третього енергетичного пакету.
Представники проекту "Північний потік-2" на запит DW
представили свою позицію з цього питання.
На початку року посол Річард Гренелл вже розсилав
німецьким компаніям, які беруть участь у
будівництві газопроводу, попереджувальні листи,
немов би з натяком на санкції.
Представники німецького бізнесу стверджують, що
такі дії викликають занепокоєння компаній з Німеччини.
У реалізації "Північного потоку-2" беруть участь
672 фірми-підрядника з усього світу.
Серед них деякі підприємства дуже вузької
спеціалізації, наприклад трубовкладальники.
Такі фірми мають унікальні технології.
Санкції проти них, щонайменше, дуже сильно
уповільнили б реалізацію усього проекту,
а в гіршому випадку його б зірвали.
На газове питання відреагувала і канцлерка Німеччини Анґела Меркель.
Під час робочої поїздки у Словаччину в четвер вона
заявила, що "Північний потік-2" не загрожує ЄС
газовою залежністю від Росії.
Чи будемо ми залежати від Росії через другу гілку газопроводу?
Моя відповідь - ні.
Якщо при цьому ми одночасно здійснимо диверсифікацію.
Німеччина будуватиме термінали для прийому зрідженого газу.
Це означає, що ми за жодних умов не збираємося
ставати залежними від Росії.
Але Росія і в часи "холодної війни" була джерелом газу.
Вона ним і залишиться. При цьому жодної
односторонньої залежності з нашого боку не буде.
Крім цього, вона підкреслила, що важливою умовою
проекту є також збереження транзиту газу через Україну.
Про необхідність диверсифікації поставок
російського газу та створення терміналів для
прийому танкерів зрідженого газу давно говорять і експерти.
Правда, перспективи американських експортерів
зрідженого газу вони оцінюють скептично.
Сьогодні вже є достатньо постачальників зрідженого газу,
які пропонують більш привабливі ціни, ніж американці.
І не варто забувати про те, що американці
видобувають газ за допомогою фрекінгу і з цим
пов'язані значні екологічні ризики.
Тому відповідь тут - зріджений газ - так,
але газ зі США - швидше ні.
При цьому, на думку експертів, будівництво "Північного потоку-2"
просунулося надто далеко і зупинити його не так просто.
Якщо, звісно, не буде сюрпризів з боку Брюсселя і ключові
країни ЄС все ж наважаться змінити правила гри для "Газпрому".